firstly i want to reiterate that our
thoughts and condolences
are with the families of olivia pratt
corbil
ashley dale and sam rimmer
thank you for all coming today and for
your continued support
as we work to identify those responsible
for these callous and cold-blooded
murders
that have rocked our communities
our officers and detectives have been
working round the clock in our
relentless pursuit to identify the
offenders and bring them to justice
we have had some phenomenal support from
the communities
in the affected areas
of dingle
old swan and dovecot
and beyond
in the form of both information coming
into the investigations
but also support for the ongoing
investigations
it's also been heartening to hear from
members of the community
who have spoken about the confidence
that they have
in us
working with the information that we've
been given
to bring those offenders to justice
over the last few days the
investigations have been moving at pace
as you would imagine
and i'd like to now hand you over to
detective chief superintendent mark
comey
who will be able to provide some more
detailed information about each of those
investigations
thank you sir
good morning everybody um
i will attempt wherever possible now
as i hopefully did in the first briefing
to be as transparent as to where the
investigation up to as possible
however
you
and everybody listening
and
watching this broadcast do need to
realize that these are ongoing
live investigations and there will be
elements of those investigations that i
am unable to talk about at this time
and i'll give a short update around each
of those investigations
i'll tackle that in chronological order
as they occur
the first murder
was of sam rimmer
sam was murdered in cold blood on the
16th of august in the area of dingle in
merseyside
firstly we are continuing to support
sam's family at this incredibly
difficult time
for each of these murders
none of us
and me certainly can even begin to
appreciate what those family members
must be going through
we have specialist officers supporting
the family
as a result of information that we've
received
and our and the work that's been
undertaken by the detective cohorts that
is uh engaged on this inquiry
we have made three arrests
those men have been arrested on
suspicion of murder
they have now been released on bail and
our inquiries continue
i would urge anybody with any
information in respect of this
investigation
this brutal murder
to come forward and engage with us
in my
first appeal
i spoke about the fact that there were
four offenders
and we believe that they arrived on two
electric bikes
i'm still interested in hearing any
information around the identity
of those four individuals
i am still interested in finding out
where the gun is that was used in that
offence
and i'm still interested in any
information
in respect of the two electric bikes
that we believe were used to convey
those four men
to the scene
i'd reiterate what mr green said at the
start
the level of support from our
communities across each of these
investigations has been phenomenal
but please let's keep that pace with the
information coming into the inquiry
so in
short who are the men that were
responsible
where are they now
where are those bikes
and where is that gun
i'll now move on to
the murder of ashley dale
ashley as we know was carelessly
murdered on the evening of the 21st of
august
and once again as with sam's family we
are continuing to support ashley's
family at this incredibly difficult time
again i'm incredibly grateful for the
level of support and engagement our
community provided to us
in relation to this murder investigation
i can also confirm that a man and woman
have been arrested
the man has been arrested on suspicion
of murder
and the woman has been
arrested uh for assisting an offender
and inquiries are continuing around
those two individuals
in my first
appeal
i asked for people to come forward who
were on foot in the street
in leinster road
and that
appeal
still stands
we know that there's still people in the
community walking around whether it be
walking home
maybe coming home from after being on a
night out
or just milling about in the street
at the time when this took place
which was at around
half past midnight
i still want those people to come
forward and make contact with us
if you have any information in relation
to this murder investigation
please
support the police inquiry
and i move on to the final murder
investigation
that of olivia pratt corbell
poor olivier
was murdered brutally
in her own home on the 22nd of august
our officers
continue to carry out extensive
inquiries
and i can confirm that there are a
number of very positive lines of inquiry
that we are pursuing
in my previous appeal
i asked for the man responsible for this
brutal
callous thoughtless attack
to surrender himself to the police
unfortunately that individual has failed
to do that
but my message to him remains the same
we will not rest until we find you
and we will find you
again
as i've said with the appeals around
both sam and ashley i cannot stress
enough the importance of community
engagement
in solving each of these crimes
we've had a wealth of information and
engagement and i'm incredibly grateful
for that
i can confirm
that the 35 year old man who was the
target of this attack
remains in hospital
seeking treatment
i can also confirm
that merseyside police
working with its partners
have caused that male's licence to be
revoked
and he'll be returned
to prison
once his treatment has been finalized
i can also confirm and ask directly
for communities to give us information
for the second man that was in company
with that 35 year old man
and again i can now confirm that we have
identified that male
i've repeatedly asked for any
information help from our communities
and as i've said already in this
conference i am incredibly grateful for
the sheer levels and volume of
information that we've received so far
this level of engagement
this level of cooperation and this level
of working together
simply must continue
i hope our communities have also seen
some of our responses over the last few
days to the information that they're
providing
i also need to remind everybody around
the mip
opportunity on our website it's the
major incident portal to upload cctv and
make contact with us directly
through the met or indeed through crime
stoppers on our 800-555-111
i would very much like to be able to
provide further information at this time
however and i hope everyone can
understand and as i said at the start
it's simply not appropriate to divulge
anything further at this stage as these
are live investigations
and we cannot do anything that would
prejudice the outcome of them
i'd also say that these investigations
are incredibly fast-paced
and
incredibly complex
but despite this
there are
multiple lines of inquiry that we are
actively pursuing
i'd like to reassure our communities
that are working relentlessly on each of
those murder investigations and those
main lines of inquiry are being pursued
effectively
i really do appreciate as i've said
repeatedly the engagement we've had thus
far i'd ask for it to continue and also
appreciate the support that we have had
from the media as well thank you very
much
thank you
so a news conference they're being held
by merseyside police and no
questions being allowed from members of
the media who were there this is a live
investigation we're told and clearly we
were given as much information as we are
going to get i think for people who were
expecting a little bit more about the
terrible killing of little of olivia
perhaps hoping for a name of this gunman
well they will be disappointed but they
will be heartened by some of uh what we
heard detective chief superintendent
mark comey
there saying that they do have a number
of positive lines of inquiry about this
callous thoughtless attack he said
there is a message that i have for that
gunman we won't rest till we find you
and we will
find you is what he said he also
reiterated didn't he a number of times
how grateful he is to the community for
the
support they're giving the police as
they carry on with this investigation
but also for the information that they
are being given there was a fear that
people would be reticent or unprepared
to
give any evidence to the police give any
information which might lead them to
the gunman but the police saying that
they've been heartened by the response
that they have had they also confirmed
what we were reporting yesterday that
there is a man being treated in hospital
he is the first man who entered olivia's
home escaping from the gunman he has
been named not by the police
interestingly but certainly by local
media as joseph knee we're told his
license will be revoked he'll return to
prison he uh remains in hospital at the
moment and also that appeal for the
second man because we know that when the
gunman was running down this avenue he
was chasing two men one man who entered
olivia's house but there was a second
man now we have been told that they know
who he is they've identified him they
didn't give a name but clearly they want
to know where he is and they hope that
people in liverpool may be able to help
them with that he said it's a fast-paced
investigation also listening in was
fraser moore fraser we'll speak about
the other two murders as well in a
moment but there will be i think a
little bit of disappointment that we
didn't get more information but it does
sound as if the police
are getting uh uh tip bits from the
community that are so desperately needed
that's right they say that they are
getting a positive response and that
they are reassuring people that if they
come forward these uh the any
information can be treated anonymously
there are numerous ways numerous ways
that people can get in touch with them
either directly they can do it through
crime stoppers which is anonymous they
can upload any footage that they've got
from cctv cameras mobile phones anything
like that on a secure portal that's
available through the merseyside police
website so we know that the local
council here set up drop-in centers for
people to come in if they don't want to
deal with the police directly they can
go and talk to local councillors in
confidence that their that their
identities won't necessarily be revealed
and that those councillors will then
pass that information out to police uh
if they keep saying all the way through
these investigations it's the public
that will hold the key to this someone
will know the name of the person
responsible for this and uh and of
course there are the there's the wall of
science that you're talking about the
grass culture that people keep referring
to here you know people will be scared
these are dangerous people and there
will of course be concerns amongst
people for their own safety for the
safeties
for the safety of their families whether
or not they are identified as someone
who's giving information to police but
people are coming forward and they are
helping and progress does seem to be
being made
okay fraser thank you very much indeed
that's the update then on the murder of
olivia pratt corbell we were also given
updates on sam rimmer three arrests have
been made on suspicion of murder
he was killed in liverpool on the 16th
of august also ashley dale killed on the
21st of august a man arrested on
suspicion of murder a woman arrested on
assisting an offender so clearly this
investigation is continuing at a pace as
we heard from merseyside police they are
pleased with the information that they
are getting from members of the public
but of course they are appealing for
more information for cctv for names
anything at all that could lead them to
the man responsible for this horrific
attack on a little girl on monday nights